with my wife she would want the extra
space country he said very very spacious
that's my watch my videos are new
Tribunal's that I do and hunger and
nothing you know I probably made that
money from there not really how I
managed to get it and what I did know
multi marketing schemes pyramid scheme
ACS none a Dem guys follow me wish it
was Cara enjoy all of your favorites
from gift owes Lahore karahi in the
comfort of your home with just a click
or a call that's not all we now offer
free delivery for all orders over 100
pounds delivery available within a
ten-mile radius with a five pound
minimum charge for the first five miles
and an additional one pound fifty per
mile thereafter enjoy a good day with a
great meal at gift days I said I'm one
econ where I'm at or a better care to
bond and sisters and dear friends I love
you guys are thinking what's this cloud
even behind me well we're gonna come
stop robbing sister now there's a
totally different video that you never
see on my channel it's a whole different
side to me I'm gonna be talking about my
success story how I made it now Robin
this is what you see behind me is a
hundred and five thousand pounds Range
Rover car Specter I want you guys to
follow me I'm gonna tell you guys a bit
about this car but I got how I managed
to get it and what I did know multi
marketing schemes pyramid scheme AC and
slanted up guys
follow me let's check this car up
Bank yep that's right
red interior one of my favorite colors
bombs and sisters jump in we come on
jump in sisters the Range Rover is one
of my dream cars I've already won with
an S class or a Range Rover red interior
what we're gonna do is were gonna test
drive this car and tell you guys a bit
about it what I have on my watch here
before any of you guys have noticed it's
a who blower fifteen fifteen thousand
pounds one five one five bonus sisters
check yourself now bone sisters a lot of
people go about things our own way yeah
I'm gonna tell you guys how to make it
in the hell on way inshallah yeah it's
not that hard and the way people make it
seem it's impossible I need to go do
drugs
none of that no yeah you guys might
watch my videos on YouTube videos that I
do and I'm doing nothing you know I
probably made that money from there
not really cause we're about five six
years I did make it in your future and I
love you guys might be watching this you
know me robbers or sisters and think you
know how how did you meet you and
happens one a sudden you're coming out
with it robbing the sisters win if I've
done spin so it fins the right way to
get this car then you can do it there's
nothing special about me if I can do it
you can do it if I have a 15 grand watch
on my hand if I can do it you can do
it's not that hard
we shouldn't be limited minded finger to
ourself how we're gonna do that it's not
that hard bounces I'm gonna take you
guys through it I want to do guys
through it how I got this car you
and before I do that though I just
wanted to because Bob insisted inshallah
and they're the one thing that I like
about Range Rovers like I like s-class
as well I could have gone for that
option for wanted to get down yeah I
could with the Range Rover handle a lot
is that it's different driving up here
you can see I'm gonna sound arrogant so
hum do a lot and there touch me
absolutely beautiful smooth you've got
two big screens and read back said
before is one of my favorite interior
colors white color white color car with
red interior it's something I've always
wanted and how I'm gonna allow you can
see yes it's a big car you're gonna be
paying a lot of money on tax and if it's
diesel its peak but between thieves now
2019 green I'm gonna laugh it's better
you're better off is it's you know it's
more economic here so it's up to you
know six standards it's a beautiful car
back is absolutely spacious and one
thing that I specifically called when I
asked is the the back seats you've got
the the thing that they had my 11 inch
screens and a lot so if you have kids
you're married boom just put the kids to
sleep in Shaba they can washed out you
want to go out for a nice drive with the
wife you don't have to learn if I'm
driving with my wife she would want the
extra space conflict it's a very very
spacious car you know for me
specifically me and my wife you know
were quite a tune so handle is
absolutely beautiful which were digital
screen right in front of me the marble
touch on the steering wheel was
absolutely
not only that the touch that I have you
the person that I have on the steering
wheel hamdulillah I striving after the
different cars before but this one is
absolutely smooth and brilliant this is
much much better but I've been in
certain raindrops before as well not
only that you can see right here on this
side as you can see I can adjust my tea
my seat from here about everything look
at this enjoy yourself this is
absolutely epic man this is a beautiful
car and I believe I've deserved it I
believe I've deserved it and because
I've worked really hard for him
inshallah now we're going to do
provinces we're gonna go to MU suppose
moose is waiting for we're gonna go pick
up insha'Allah
and we're going to give a little
reminder on this inshaallah because it's
very important for bonuses out there
that are watching that might not have
the means to buy a car like this you
know and we're gonna give a little
reminder so everyone can benefit from it
inshaallah
and we can talk about how to go about
things in a halal way you know i can do
it you guys can do it hoping to discuss
this with Moses rockers Moses wasn't
involved of me getting this Kai's one in
shanwa we're gonna talk about the anal
work so let's check out sure do keep
tuning in shoppers about some amazing
amazing surprises for you guys in shower
here's Musa so I make a Maki how you
doing
yeah good ham they are not bad okey I
think this belongs to your friend now ah
bless him preserve them weak you can
give that to him
Brahmins and sisters if you're suffering
from mental illness depression suicide
you're gonna be thinking what the hell
is going on brah Valley Valley you're
jumping into a range of 105 gram car
you're just giving a worker that doesn't
even belong to you this car here is a
Toyota Prius
yes as you guys can see this is the car
that I Drive from a day to day living
now you didn't see our brother Ali here
we go again with the clickbait hold on
Moosa is it gonna be worth the wait
follow us okay we're gonna explain why
we're gonna explain why follow us
oh okay what's up welcome to the car
that I got not Mort I've got yes I've
got it yeah evil chauffeurs may Allah
bless inshallah they arranged this car
for us to be driven now we're gonna get
straight into a bomb sisters before you
guys start bugging out
clickbait there is a very specific
purpose we're doing this video we've
traveled outside longer to find a
specific place well through all this
hassle to bring this video to you guys
but there's a specific reason why now
Moussa when I spoke to you on the phone
yesterday when I want to do the video I
was very passionate if you heard it from
the worse because I was very very
frustrated the reason why I was
frustrated a key is because I see a lot
of people claiming freedom like said
okay you know what look I'm I'm free I
can do where for one extra thing to
myself really like oh you really feel
like I'm genuinely looking and think to
myself are you really free and then I
look back into my lifestyle before I can
yeah okay I would want to drive cars
like this yeah and by the way let's make
it very clear there is nothing wrong
with driving cars like this nobody
saying is Haram which we're going to
come to this is not what this is about
brothers and sisters we have so many
social influences which we're not going
to name we don't need to name it's no
point that they're doing all kinds of
stuff some of them a person is
struggling struggling
however brothers and sisters when they
come and give you a specific lifestyle
which they make themselves not even own
or have but when they rub it in your
face the question that needs to be asked
is what do you what do you get out of
doing that what is the purpose of doing
that now if I genuinely owned this car
and if I had the mist on this car I
would there's nothing wrong with that
don't get it twisted as long as you give
me the car I'm helping the people etc
there is nothing wrong with owning a
nice car or a nice watch the point is
not that as the wrong cos you're
carrying money in your hand and not in
your heart but what's happening today
Musa and correct me if I'm wrong we're
having a lot of youngsters falling into
depression suicide self-doubt sisters
doubting option I wear my hijab I don't
know I need to look this way social
pressure
brothers go in doing drugs etc why
because I want to drive nice cars
because that's what people are looking
for yeah is that your phone okay
so that's what people are looking for
and I figured to myself wow if people
can
tend pretend that they all cause that
they don't drive for a perception on a
video I'm thinking wow if that is not
the biggest enslavement and slavery of
invisible shackles that we have that we
don't see what lying I don't know what
it is bro and a lot of you guys that are
watching this you may have fought some
of you guys admit what is the thing you
know what look at this guy evil has it
you know and subhanAllah
I don't even own the car the watch that
this is this is actually 15 brand watch
that a brother owns me Allah bless him
he works hard if he deserves there is
nothing wrong with that the point is as
social influences we have
responsibilities if I have this car I'm
not gonna flesh in your face because why
do I need to and and no new youngsters
that are watching this brothers and
sisters one lie he let me be honest with
Moosa if we had this kind of watch in
your hand and he was driving this kind
of car what's the possibility if he was
to propose to a sister that they'll be
saying no now let's be real no let's be
real a Kiwi having a real Tokyo they're
gonna go for you why why do they care
about liquor suppose you don't even
dressing up like this yeah you just up
lucky yeah okay the point is imagine bro
the respect you will have you know what
the thing is earlier everyone wants
happiness something like yeah everyone
wants to feel happy and from a young age
the society that we live in and we live
in in a global society so it doesn't
even matter if you're from a third world
countries to we've still got the
Internet you're looking at all of these
things online you're looking at all of
these musicians and movies and one on
all of these mediums of of of media
right yeah and you see these people who
are who look successful to you yeah not
the the epitome of success you see these
people and they've got watches like this
they've got cars like this so what you
do is subsequently you equate success
and Happiness with these items
yes do you understand yeah so I would
even go as far as to say can you blame a
sister for falling for that sometimes
you may not be able to you know why
because her image of happiness lies in
these things
and the thing is it's very very sad
because when you do have these things
you know you actually realize hang on a
second it's not all about these things
and if you were to meet people I'll give
you an example man just watch you know
it's actually 10,000 pounds though I
don't think it makes a difference to
people whether it's 15,000 pounds yeah
10,000 pounds is that right it's a very
very expensive watch enough yeah yeah
the brother who gave this watch to me I
just called him he's a good friend of
mine yeah I called it you know can you
give it to me etc yeah he gave me the
watch to borrow and we're using it for
this video now
but he wasn't attached with the watch in
that way and that's something you know
one thing I noticed yeah you know when
we got the watch yes I said if you get
summiting responsibility he said okay
don't worry
yeah and I was that good cuz if that was
me fact that kind of money I'm not gonna
give that yes and this is the thing bro
and I was speaking to the brother from
English office because we came I came in
this car and one of the things I was
speaking to him about is that these
people of he Allah he puts her love in
the people for these type of people who
are like this and it reminded me of a
hadith that the prophet sallallaahu
sanam said is it fit dunya you hymnbook
Allah that if you have zuid detachment
from the dunya Allah will love you
was it FEMA in the NASS you have book
your hip book on us that have jihad be
detached from what is with the people
the people will love you so hadith of
the Prophet solanum that if you detach
from these things of the dunya of what
people have you know cars and you know
shoes and watches and what people will
love you people will love you for that
and when this brother gave me this I
loved him move for that when I see
brothers like the brothers from you know
Eagles chauffeurs and they're driving
these very very nice cars but at the
same time they're willing you know to
give their calls out for Dawa and all of
these things you love them so the point
is this all stems from an image of
happiness that people have they think if
they have this they're gonna be happy
and not only that but now we can speak
about the sisters you know impression
that they have etc but there are
brothers out there killing other
brothers for this bro there are brothers
out there killing man's on the road for
postcards and drugs thought to drive to
have this lifestyle so it's not even a
matter of influence and it just makes
depressed a bit you're out there killing
believers the froster sent them said a
believers blood is more dear than the
Cabbot I lost a panatela brothers and
sisters this even ties into marriage a
key yeah this even ties into marriage
that people are influenced for example
by the impression so for example if a
brother looks a certain way as a certain
way
sister wear the hijab on the table
that's it and that's why it's so sad
that we attach I would tell soft
influences that if they was supposed to
take the hijab off sisters we even the
brothers stop bugging up and I thought
to myself I was really bugging about
about yes okay side may Allah make it
easy but the point here is this we have
attached ourself to outer exterior
things both aesthetics and materialism
so much so that it comes from the truth
from the people that would take
knowledge to he looks the part he has
books behind him he says Yanni she bid
that move today he knows what he's
talking about if he is for example
driving a car the stub of this guy's
making money is that Alan harem you
don't know you don't care not if he's
making it he's making it when it comes
to even marriage okay oh if that sisters
dressing up in this way or that way or
brother looks like that he must be right
for you how do you know I'm gonna make
some 4 verses for you in the Quran which
I find absolutely profound and out I use
this to develop people into a little
business - I'm starting I'm going to
launch inshallah very soon this year
because it ties into the marriage
problem a key why because again Allah
says in the Quran which I can't I don't
miss the verse of my hapa put it on
screamed over the sisters here I'm
trying to memorize verses remember Samia
but the thing is promises allah subhanaw
taala talks in four specific paths Allah
says in the Quran that we have sent the
clothing to cover your shame but indeed
the clothing of taqwa is more like
beloved number one number two allah
subhanho wa taala says in surah Baqarah
that it is not righteousness and piety
is not turning your face to the east or
the west okay good
another verse in the Quran offensive
surah hajj allah subhanaw taala says it
is not the slaughtering of the animal
it's not the flesh or the blood that
reaches Allah but it is the taqwa then
also panowitz other talks about the
munafa kun and the mana 15 and they're
talking about the Masjid what support
the message the message there are a nun
last seen it is more beloved likes more
better than ego
worshipping the minister of taqwa so now
let's check this out from the clothes
that you wear to the fete that into the
direction that you face to the animal
that you slaughter to the place that you
worship Allah is talking about aqua aqua
aqua aqua aqua is that's was a lots to
learn lesson look the flesh of brothers
and reach me the clothing is good but in
the talk was important righteous is not
facing right left or right the message
of taco is most deserving of a place to
be worshipped brothers and sisters how
many of us get affected subhanAllah that
when we look at somebody's in a taqwa
like for example why is it that when is
an outer garment it's all superficial
and promises you're looking at these
laughter of these public figures wallahi
most of them you don't even know that
very sister who's putting that pictures
of everything looks amazing they're on
holiday you thinking they're in gender
well I don't even know if she is getting
abused by a husband if she's getting
beat by her husband and she's covering
up with makeup and you don't this point
is a very very important point that I
wanted to touch upon and and this is one
of the reasons I wanted one of the
things I wanted to speak about in this
video is that brothers and sisters when
you see people online take what what you
see with a pinch of salt
cut even when you see scholars when you
see you online
take that with a pinch of salt what do I
mean I'll take the knowledge with a
pinch of salt now you benefit from the
knowledge what I'm saying is your
perceptions your perceptions of people
because here's the thing earlier
we both have social medias yeah have you
ever made a video crying on social media
when when when you're in a depressed
state yeah and since I've known you in
the years I've known you have you not
been in states like that of course you
have and I have as well and many other
people have as well and all of the
teachers you look up to and even the
shook that you look up to they have down
times and they have up times but here's
the thing now when you're going through
a down time it's not a natural reaction
to get the camera out and say guys I'm
going through a down time that's not
sellable it's not marketable it doesn't
help you it's bad for your marketing it
looks bad on you
yeah people people say we heard that
guy's depressed what you know this guy
that guy's crying on camera what why is
he doing that for what that that guy's
insecure about his his his body what
why is he
secure about his body what not and how
is insecurity seen as a positive thing
no it's seen as a negative thing
yes yeah so that sister that you're
looking at for example for the sisters
and she puts herself off as very very
perfect and whatnot how do you know
she's not extremely insecure extremely
insecure about her body about her face
about etc so what I'm saying is all of
these things you have to take them with
a pinch of salt and you have to realize
even about yourself your own social
media now let's talk about your own
social media you're not a public figure
so you don't really have this repertoire
and this kind of reputation to keep up
to you don't have that but you yourself
let me ask you a question now you've
just had an argument with your dad your
dad's really really angry with you you
just had an argument with your wife your
wife is swearing at you are you gonna
vlog that and put it on YouTube if
you're gonna do that you're not gonna do
that are we gonna do that of course
we're not gonna do that and this is the
thing that we're talking about here you
know when we talk about some of the
earlier generations are they the earlier
generations and even if we talk about
amongst of Sahaba we know some of the
mistakes that they made yes and I'm not
saying that and this is an important
clarification to say all the Sahaba like
this didn't no no no no no don't don't
misconstrue what I'm trying to say here
what I'm trying to say is these people
are here they made mistakes and the
Prophet solanum reprimanded them and
corrected them for their mistakes but
they were not rich enough if they made a
mistake the earlier generations they
made mistakes
scholars earlier they made mistakes
right but you know what the difference
is between us and them we know about the
mistakes yes
you know today no one knows our mistakes
exactly but this is the point where we
wonder we wanted to break that trend so
the whole reason I went to my car I'm
driving a Toyota Prius I do
uber yeah I do uber now I put the out
there for a variety of reasons yeah
number one to smash this perception
because some people have become that -
yeah
the guy is shocked he's thinking like
okey there was one guy he was going
through some kind of depression yeah I
spoke to me cuz we were called Yankee
it's as if no in a bad way there was
some kind of ease on his heart the fact
that I'm going through a struggle
brothers and sisters I have no shame I'm
an uber driver if
you're earning a halal income Toyota
Prius Bravo moderator please Hunter's
got a reverse camera like this car it
might not be as crisp Barca steel will
still see it takes me from A to B it's
comfortable brothers and sisters don't
get married bishop look I'm do you know
what my wife accepted me with that
hamdulillah brothers and sisters this is
what we're talking about I would rather
do that then marry somebody that see me
driving this car and then when I go
broke because let me tell you something
I'm looking at the turf zero of surah
yousuf moosa alaih-is-salaam moosa
aleihsalaam started off as a baby in the
kingdom of faroan he ended up as a walk
shepherd you somebody salam started off
as well with his brothers learning to be
a shepherd and ended up in the kingdom
of a well they want pharaohs at those
hands a ruler king yeah okay look where
your position can be it can change the
day you drive in this tomorrow your
position can change it look at a
person's taqwa look at them for who they
are not what they have got what they
have can go so we're here to break that
trend do you not look a soldier in
France don't look at us and think our
lifestyles are this trust me most of
them are fake I'm telling you I'm a good
driver
what do you mean I think Ali is very
very important to clarify it yes when we
say fake what does that mean that means
that means yeah that when you see for
example and this look unfortunately we
have to be very rude is there may be
some people watching this that listen to
music they see some of these rappers and
whatnot yeah these rappers right they're
from Council of states etc and I'm not
saying that that's bad yeah no they brag
about that I grew up in Islam and
whatnot oke are you telling me that that
you're still in Islam
yeah and they and they're doing this
they it's this guy's first video house
he's got Ferrari in his first video
where did this money run man he come
from he's got a who blow in his first
video like this one where did that money
come from husky you have to understand
with these industries there's a concept
where it's called fake it till you make
it
yeah they go enjoy until you who is that
rapper who was caught was his name Bow
Wow Bow Wow yeah he got caught brothers
and sisters this is enslavement
I'm gonna wrap up with this brothers and
sisters anybody if you're watching this
and you're in the psychological stay
where you're thinking you have to prove
yourself be you a hijab' taking a hijab
off looking a certain way
after certain way be your brother doing
drugs at this now waiver you are
literally enslaved
you are literally enslaved that you're
being forced to do things that you don't
even want to do slave to the mizzou are
enslaved to your society I'm so sorry
it's as simple as that break those
shackles because I gained my freedom the
piece Hum Dil I have in my heart I'm a
Alice mother give it to all of you guys
you can put me in kingdoms and
fortresses and cars and Rolls Royce
whoever provide that piece is not gonna
be giving them this is Osama bin Tamiya
you know he expressed that what can they
do to me and we know Chicano son was
imprisoned he went through a lot and and
he said that what can they do to me you
know the way he expressed so what can
they do to me
you know I have peace in my heart you
know I have found that contingent
contentment in my heart these people
they can't do anything to me and that's
what you have 10 December of ancestors
that success is not in what the eye sees
the cars and whatnot and that we're not
saying that to be cliche here we're
saying the dunya has got its place yes
we love things of the dunya you do as
well and I do as well and we own things
of the dunya I like certain things that
I own and I would love it but how would
I love it yes I would love it in in in
it I would put it in its position yes I
would put it in my hand not in my heart
and this is something that we need to
understand and I'll leave it with a
quote it's a very beautiful book that
I'm currently reading
it's by sister Yasmin Raja head is
called weekly it's cool reclaim your
heart yeah and she speaks about an
amazing she gives an amazing and amazing
analogy and she gives the analogy of the
ocean the ocean has water in it my dear
brothers and sisters
the boat the vessel that is on the ocean
that is floating it's floating the ocean
is the dunya and it is literally an
ocean women cause watches Jews all of
the glasses and all of the designer
things you can get designer Versace
Gucci Fendi shoes and all of these
things that's that's the ocean and you
are the boat and your heart is inside
the boat what this is a given the
analogy is if
boat allows for all of that ocean to
come onboard and to you know get into
the boat and what know what's gonna
happen to that boat it's gonna sink it's
gonna capsize and it's gonna be Hollis
right but what the boat does is it
accepts the dunya it accepts the ocean
and it glides on top of it is it stay it
floats it stays in its place so with the
dunya my dear brothers and sisters keep
it in its place don't put it in your
heart don't make it your identification
for success that's not what success is
about and I mean we've come to a stage
anywhere even non-muslims are realizing
this with with movements like minimalism
and and and which which is pretty much
you know very similar to Seward and with
movements like you know stoicism and
these sort of fill Asif ease that people
are talking about so brothers and
sisters Allah told you this
you know fourteen hundred years ago you
know you don't need you know any exams
but to tell you this thank you